what's up guys bang bang huge week in
the Bitcoin industry first Bitcoin is up
74 year-to-date that is a big big number
because go back just about four or five
months ago and everyone thought Bitcoin
was over they were talking about the
fact that Bitcoin was going to 10K all
the nonsense they were wrong Bitcoin up
74 to start the year the best performing
asset of q1 now it's not just price
that's going up though we also have more
Bitcoin transactions than ever before we
continue to see all sorts of Innovations
and experimentation that's happening on
top of Bitcoin and that is leading to
more people using the network on top of
more transactions we also have hash rate
hitting an all-time high in fact we've
had the largest five-day increase in
history and hash rate that tells you
that regardless of price being up or
down hash rate continues to increase and
the network continues to get more secure
now why do I say regardless of price up
or down it's because if hash rate is
coming online now IT it isn't like they
decided last week to start to install it
instead there are months and months of
lead time between when someone decides
to set up Mining and when they actually
get it online and so much of the hash
rate that's coming online now probably
was decided back in 2022 when price was
falling aggressively now not only has
the price of Bitcoin fell last year and
recovered this year but the price of
banks continues to be in free fall not
only do we get First Republic Bank going
into receivership Monday morning and
then its assets being sold to JP Morgan
in a sweetheart deal but on top of that
we've seen Regional Banks continue to
fail left and right and some of their
stocks are down more than 50 percent in
a single day now of course if banks are
having trouble especially if they're
going into receivership and they
continue to have all sorts of difficulty
on their financial balance sheets
Americans get worried there's a new
Gallup pull out that shows that almost
50 percent of Americans are either very
or moderately worried about the safety
of their Bank deposits now I personally
don't think that your bank deposit is in
trouble but I do understand why so many
people are worried people just want to
be cautious and when you have your life
savings sitting in a bank account you
want to make sure that you're going to
have access to it now it's 48 of all
Americans say that they're very or
moderately worried which is more than
the 45 percent of Americans who said
that they were worried back during the
2008 Global financial crisis right after
Lehman collapsed as we see more and more
Americans starting to get worried that
puts the Federal Reserve the FDIC and
other organizations into a really weird
situation do they save the banks or do
they save the dollar I personally
believe that they will continue to save
the banks we can't have depositors being
so freaked out that they begin to pull
all of their money causing more Bank
runs on some of these financial
institutions and so naturally whether
they're using the deposit Insurance Fund
or they are going to use other
government programs or funds there's
going to be inflationary pressure on the
US dollar now of course we see the
headline CPI number continue to fall all
down to five percent based on the March
numbers but we have to understand that
the month over month inflation continues
to accelerate in January we had point
five percent growth over December in
February we had point four percent
growth over January and in March we had
0.1 percent growth over February that
means that inflation is actually
accelerating it is not going negative
yet so don't be fooled by that headline
number now of course that runs right
back into Bitcoin being up 74 to start
the year if inflation is actually
increasing even though the headline
number doesn't show it there's probably
a lot of folks who look at Bitcoin as a
potential solution to that inflation on
top of that if there continues to be
more problems with the banks Bitcoin
fixes that as well you see more and more
people opting to buy Bitcoin hold their
private keys and become their own bank
and then don't forget that we have the
looming debt limit Crisis coming up in
June the United States government is
broke we've hit the debt limit and
unless politicians can get together and
raise the debt limit there could be a
potential U.S default now now again I
don't believe that the United States is
going to default but I do think that
investors around the world they want to
be hedged and what is a better way to
get hedge to a potential us default than
to buy an asset that's in an alternative
Financial system and that is something
that Bitcoin continues to serve as a
potential solution for now last but not
least Robert F Kennedy one of the top
environmental lawyers in the United
States has come out in strong support of
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies this is a
huge deal because we recently saw the
Biden Administration propose legislation
that would Levy a 30 percent tax against
all minors consuming electricity for the
purpose of mining cryptocurrency now the
reason why Robert F Kennedy is so
interesting to me put aside all of the
politics but he's one of the top
environmental lawyers and if he's coming
out and saying these Technologies are
not bad for the environment in fact
they're good for the environment that
puts a stop to many of the different
critics argument Robert F Kennedy is
gaining Steam and his political campaign
seems to be getting more attention if
he's going to be a proponent of Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies that likely will be
a Tailwind for the industry we're coming
up on the Bitcoin conference and it
seems like Bitcoins price rally plus
some of the support from politicians and
various other people in the media
combined with that Bitcoin conference
likely will serve to be a fun start to
the summer hope that you're enjoying
these updates every single Saturday
morning and I will see you all next week